Hi,
this video has two components,
a three minute announcement of the
remaining venues of my American 12 rules
for life tour and the new Canadian
venues that will open up in July and
August,
followed by a lengthy discussion with
Ben Shapiro on the narrative substrate.
If human cognition derive from his new
Sunday Youtube video and podcast.
So either I'm in Denver,
Colorado today.
It's May 7th,
2018.
I'm going to give the fourth talk of my
American 12 rules for life to her
tonight.
Or maybe it's the fifth.
First one was Toronto in Washington,
then Chicago and Detroit.
Now Denver.
So yes,
I guess that's the fifth.
I'm announcing the remaining venues
today in the u.
s where tickets are still available and
the dates and places for my Canadian
tour.
10 Canadian cities in July.
So there's tickets remaining to 10
venues in the United States on May
Twenty Third Philadelphia on May 29th,
Houston on June dates Richmond on June
10th,
Charlotte,
June twelfth,
Nashville,
June 14th,
Louisville,
June 15th,
Indianapolis,
June Sixteenth,
Milwaukee Twenty Fifth,
Portland Twenty Seventh,
Sacramento.
And in between all that on Wednesday
that June the fifth,
I'll also be enriched vic in Iceland,
so tickets are available for those.
And then I'm going to be touring Canada
in July and August the 19th in Toronto
on the 20th in Hamilton.
That's July again.
Twenty first in London,
Ontario,
22nd in kitchener onto on the 23rd in
Ottawa on the 26th in Vancouver on the
27th in Calgary on the 28th in Edmonton
in August on the 14th at Regina and on
August 15 in saskatoon,
Saskatchewan.
You can find out more about that if you
go to Jordan b Peterson.com
and look up events.
That's Jordan Peterson.com
under events also in this video is a
discussion that I recently did last
week.
In fact it was just released with Ben
Shapiro as part of his New Sunday
podcast initiative and I think we had a
very good conversation and so the rest
of this video is taken up with the
conversation that I had with Ben.
I think we got farther on the issue of
how human perception and cognitive
function is nested inside a fundamental
narrative substrate and we related that
to modern findings,
neuropsychology related to hemispheric
function.
I think it was an excellent discussion
and so I'm very happy to bring it to
you.
There's some ads in it because I took it
directly from Ben's video,
so anyways,
so that's the tour.
Philadelphia,
Houston,
Richmond,
Charlotte,
Nashville,
Louisville,
Indianapolis,
Milwaukee,
Portland and Sacramento and that's all
in June and May and then rick to vic and
June as well,
and then the candidate tour in July and
August.
Toronto,
Hamilton,
London,
kitchener,
Ottawa,
Vancouver,
Calgary,
Edmonton,
Regina and Saskatoon.
And as I said,
you can find out about that at Jordan b
Peterson dotcom events.
Thank you very much and I hope that you
can come to one of the talks so they
seem to be going really well so far.
We sold out a very large number of them
and the people seemed quite enthusiastic
and I've been able to get farther in my
thinking than I was in my book and each
of the talks is designed to eliminate a
different element of the,
let's say,
the 12 rules and the topics that are
associated with that.
Um,
so thanks very much and I hope you enjoy
the discussion with Ben Shapiro.
There's lots of times in your life
you're not going to be happy.
And so that's not gonna work.
You want to have something meaningful
that's the boat that will take you
through the storm.
Well,
here we are with Jordan Peterson and I
could not be more excited to talk with
he best selling author of 12 rules for
life and I will talk with them.
But first I want to say thanks for our
sponsors over at Helix sleep.
So there's nobody on the planet like
you.
So why would you buy a mattress belt for
everyone else?
Working with the world's leading sleep
experts?
Helix sleep developed a mattress that's
customized to your specific height,
weight,
and sleep preferences.
So you can have the best sleep of your
life and unbeatable price.
Here's how it works.
You go to [inaudible] dot com,
fill out their two minutes sleep quiz,
and they'll design your custom mattress.
They even customize each side for you.
And a partner in 2018 helix sleep has
taken customized sleep to the next level
with their helix pillow.
It really is fantastic.
They're all new pillows are fully
adjustable so you can achieve perfect
comfort regardless of sleep position or
body type effects.
Sleep has thousands of five star
reviews,
plus you get 100 nights to try them out.
But a helix sleep.com/ben
guest right now and you'll get up to 125
bucks towards your mattress order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash ben
guest for up to $125 off your mattress
order.
Again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash Ben.
Guests get to deal with Ben Guests and
make sure that they know that we sent
you.
Okay.
So I could not be more excited to speak
with Jordan Peterson.
Well,
as Jordan knows before the show,
we talk for an hour before the judges
got interesting things we should have
caught on tape,
but now we're actually going to get a
chance to do it live.
So here is the Jordan's new book.
If you haven't bought it yet,
everybody on planet has bought this
book.
I was walking through the office today.
We didn't have a copy in the office.
The person,
the front desk had a copy of book just
sitting on your desk.
So that's the way this works.
At 12 rules for life.
An antidote to casper,
fantastic book.
Obviously tapping all the best seller
lists all over the world.
Jordan,
thanks so much for joining the show.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks for the invitation.
You know,
obviously your,
your prominence has just blown up in the
year and a half when we were talking
before the show about why that is and
why there are so many people who
suddenly are very angry about you.
I notice there was an article in
politico suggesting that young,
angry white males,
your now their leader.
So congratulations.
I wanted to ask you about that.
Why do you think that,
number one,
your profile has become so big of late
and number two,
why do you think it is that so many
members of the of the left are so angry
about that?
Why are they characterizing people who
listen to you as angry and enraged?
Young white men?
We could look at the the
characterization
to begin with,
you know,
because I think it speaks to the
pathology of the radical left instantly.
There are absolutely incapable of
viewing the world except through group
identity terms.
Know when.
So if someone comes out and disagrees
with them,
then they have to characterize them by
their fundamental group attribute,
whatever that happens to be.
Maybe it's gender because that's a
favorite or maybe it's race and so angry
white men young.
There'll be go sexist,
ageist,
and racist all at once.
Right?
They're angry young white men.
Well,
it has to be that way.
If you're going to be the.
If you're going to play the left,
this game because that's the only way
that you can look at the world and then
if you can't make your opponent
reprehensible in some manner and it's
strange that they would attempt to make
them reprehensible on the grounds of
race,
age,
sex since that's precisely what they
stand against hypothetically,
but if you can't make your enemy
reprehensible along some dimension,
then you have to contend with them
seriously and so you know,
if I'm not an outright right fascist
like Hitler or Milo Yiannopoulos,
which was how I was characterized in
Canada because the radical leftists
can't even get their bloody insults
straight.
He's like Hitler or Milo Yiannopoulos
because there's no difference between
them.
Right?
No obvious difference.
It's just another attempt to pilloried
as far as I can tell,
and I think that it's.
It's dreadful.
I really think it is.
There was an article written by the,
by,
I believe the editor of the New York
review of books that was just
republished in the globe and Mail.
Talking about the emergence of
hypermasculinity and how I was somehow
responsible for that are contributing to
it like most Fellini and I read that and
I thought,
yeah,
like miscellaneous and I thought,
okay,
so what are you doing?
I see you're,
you're defining masculinity are
conflating masculinity and
hypermasculinity at the same time.
Then your virtue signaling by being
against hypermasculinity,
but really what you're trying to do is
bring down whatever it is that's
masculinity and what masculinity is in
in this frame is something like
competence and so it's part of the
radical leftists,
general war on competence.
It all as well,
which I think is one of the most
pernicious elements of the culture wars,
the dissolution of hierarchies.
They the assumption that every hierarchy
has to be based on power and serve the
needs of your group.
Whatever that happens to be,
that there's no such thing as competence
and so and then the other thing that's
reprehensible about it because that's
not enough,
is that it's just wrong.
Like there's.
I've got tens of thousands of letters
from people and people come up to me all
the time on the street.
I'll give you an example.
This is a great story.
This is really touching.
So I was in la about a month and a half
ago and I was downtown La and downtown
La.
It's kind of rough and I was wondering
around and with my wife and this young
guy pulled the car up beside you,
knocked out and he was kind of a stylish
look in 21 year old Latino guy,
something like that.
It was all excited.
He said,
he asked me who I was and I told him and
he,
you know,
that's what he had presumed and so he
was kind of excited about that and he
said,
look,
I've watched all your lectures and it's
really helped me and I've been
straightening out my life and trying to
get my room clean.
Me laughed about that,
but you know,
developing some names and trying to tell
the truth and,
and look,
I've really fixed up my relationship
with my father.
And so then he said,
wait,
just wait a minute.
And I thought,
sure,
sure.
And so he went back in the car and God
is farther out of his car and he came
over with his dad like they have their
arms around each other and he said,
look,
we've really improved our relationship
and they were both smiling away.
And you know that man,
if you're going to target me for that,
just go right ahead.
Sounds real white supremacist.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And,
and it's wherever I go now,
and this is one of the things,
this is the thing that's so wonderful
about that,
all of this as far as I'm concerned,
is that people come up to me all the
time and that's exactly what they say.
They say,
look,
I was lost,
aimless,
depressed,
nihilistic.
I'm anxious.
Drug addicted,
alcoholic wasting my time masturbating
too much.
Although they don't generally use that
particular example last essentially and,
and,
and hopeless in some sense.
And I've been watching your lectures and
they've really helped and I've really
been putting my life together and I'd
been trying to say what I believe to be
true and develop a vision.
And it's really helped and like,
and it's so overwhelming,
you know,
like if I'm doing book signings after a
talk,
then they'll be a dozen people or more
who and these aren't like I'm only
talking to people for about 15 seconds,
but you can have a very intense
conversation in 15 seconds and they'll
say,
look,
you know,
I like,
I was suicidal man.
Like I was really hanging onto the edge
of the earth by my fingernails and I'm
better.
And they have tears in their eyes.
It's like,
it's amazing.
Middle with that goes a long way,
man.
I think that when I look at,
at your rise and look,
I talked to people who love what you do.
I mean,
every time I go on the road and I'm
speaking at a campus,
you're the number one name that gets
mentioned at people by people who come
to my lectures.
And I think that the reason for that
that I've,
that I've seen is,
is really twofold.
One is that one of the things that you
really talk a lot about is the notion of
self discipline and purpose in your life
and control.
And the idea that you are in control of
your decision making and your decision
making matters,
that's one.
And the other is that you have,
you have a unique capacity to say no to
things and when somebody says something
to you that is illogical but popular,
that you have the capacity to say no.
That's what happened in that Kathy
Newman interview that somebody was
saying to you that made no sense
and you just said,
well no.
And then you just stood on that now and
when you stand on that.
No,
I think it gives people a lot of
courage.
Yeah,
well I mean the,
the,
the gender issue is really an
interesting one because one of my
professional domains of expertise is
individual differences.
I'm,
I'm a personality psychologist and so I
know the gender difference literature
and it's,
it's a very solid literature.
Well first of all it's very solid.
It has a 30 year history once per
psychologists got the personality models
down.
So that would be the big five model.
All empirically derived straight
statistics,
right?
Brute Force empiricism.
Nobody had a theoretical ax to grind
with the big five except to say maybe
there are human traits.
Maybe they're encapsulated in language.
We can use statistical techniques to
find out what they are.
That was it.
That's the whole ideology,
so very,
very neutral.
As far as ideology,
school five traits emerge.
Okay.
Are there differences between the sexes?
Turns out there are all right.
They're not massive,
although a few some them across all the
traits you can separate men and women
with about 75 percent accuracy,
so it's not trivial,
but you have to sum across all the
traits.
Then another question comes up,
well,
are those differences social,
cultural or biological?
Okay.
We can test that.
We'll go around.
The world will look at cultures will
rank order them in terms of the gender,
equality of their sociological policies.
We can do that with broad agreement from
the right and the left.
Then the hypothesis would be if gender
differences decrease among more
egalitarian societies,
then the gender differences are
sociocultural or at least more associate
culture.
That's exactly the opposite of what was
found repeatedly that pseudo science.
It's like,
no,
that's mainstream psychology.
Those papers have thousands of citations
and right.
The average humanities paper has zero
citations,
right?
And then the next most common one has
one,
3000.
That's an.
That's an unbelievable classic.
And,
and here's the other bit of fruit.
Like you say,
well,
how do you know that you can trust
someone's judgment about a fact.
The fact emerges despite their
ideological presuppositions.
Okay,
so it's well known that the social
sciences and the humanities have a,
have a left tilt and a lot of that's
temperamental and the tilt has become
more pronounced.
But as Jonathan hightest pointed out,
there are no conservatives among social
personality psychologist or,
or,
or none to speak of.
Very few,
vanishingly few.
And if the field has a bias,
it is definitely and indisputably a left
wing bias.
Okay,
so you have to fight that if you're,
if you're a scientist,
right?
Even if you're left wing scientists,
you have to fight that because you want
to get to the facts.
It was these social scientists who
generated the data that suggested that
the gender differences not only were
real,
but that were bigger and to Galitary and
societies.
They didn't do that to grind the
radiological acts because they're
ideological.
Presupposition was,
no,
no.
You make the society you get with
Terrian men and women get more of the
same.
It's like,
nope,
they get more different.
Oh,
isn't that something?
And so then there's a corollary there,
which is all right.
You could still say,
and they're kind of pushing in this
direction in Scandinavia,
boys and girls are different.
Men and women are different.
It looks biological,
but because people are malleable,
you could push the sociocultural
structure harder and harder to minimize
the biological differences.
Okay,
well first of all,
maybe and maybe not.
Maybe you get a rebound and they'd get
even like the kids would rebel.
That could easily happen,
but let's say,
okay,
you could.
The problem with that is,
is that if you see that much power to
the state,
like you're basically giving the state
the right to socialize your kids,
right?
It's like you,
you really,
you really want to do that.
I mean,
the people in Israel couldn't do that
with the cabooses,
right?
It didn't work.
So people aren't going to give up their
children to the state and thank God for
that.
Well,
I mean this is one of the big questions
that we were discussing earlier is that
we were talking about the polarization
in politics between right and left and
obviously you're,
you're a psychologist,
you're a philosopher,
but you've been dragged almost kicking
and screaming into this political sphere
because everything has been so
politicized.
And so when you say,
when you say social science statistics
and they are scientifically based,
you're called a racist.
You're called the sexist or called a
homophobe and all my.
Exactly.
So it was a.
Why is it that?
So why do you think it is that so many
folks on the left who purport to be all
about reason and science and and
objective factors,
so willing to throw those out the window
the minute that it becomes politically
inconvenient because you imagine that
cognitive system,
so an interpretation of the world has
levels there.
Axiomatic levels,
some fundamental presuppositions are
more fundamental than others and you
could say,
well,
the leftists historically maybe because
of their atheistic rationality are more
on the side of science than say the
fundamentalists of any sort,
but when push comes to shove,
you find out how the axioms or are
nested.
There's deeper axioms underneath that
which is that all hierarchies are based
on power and all power plays are based
on group identity,
tribal identity essentially,
and that the entire history of the world
is nothing but a power play between
between these different identity groups.
It's like,
okay,
well if the science indicates that some
of that's wrong,
then do you alter those beliefs or do
you alter the science?
And the answer to that question is,
well,
it depends on how you've hierarchically
arranged those.
If the science is at the bottom,
then you alter your beliefs,
right?
If it's the scientific facts or the
axiomatic some structure,
then you then you altered your beliefs.
If your beliefs are the axiomatic
substructure,
then you alter the science.
While we've seen how that plays out,
and one of the things I've tried to do
so to speak is to diagnose the axiomatic
structure.
It's like,
okay,
what's the.
What's the metaphysical presumption
structure of the radical left?
Well,
what what it is is your basically your
group.
Your groups are basically engaged in
warfare,
right,
and the warfare is arbitrary except in
so far as it serves your group.
Okay.
I don't buy any of that.
I think that's.
I think that's a route to certain
disaster.
I think it's a degeneration into
tribalism and that we will seriously pay
for it,
not only because it returns us to
tribalism and tribes fight as the
anthropological evidence for that is
overwhelming,
right?
Tribes spite.
It doesn't even matter if they're
chimpanzee tribes.
Even chimpanzee tribes fight.
So not only do you regress to a
tribalism,
but you also invalidate the one
proposition that's been able to help us
rise above the tribal,
which is the idea that the individual
should be sovereign.
And so I think the culture war is about
what's the proper framework within which
to view human identity and what's the
relationship between the individual and
the group in relationship to that
identity.
And the leftist answer is it's all group
and it's all powered like.
Okay.
So just a second.
I want to ask you a little bit about
some of the,
some of the more enlightenment minded
thinkers who are out there right now
because it seems like we've been
discussing the big gap in,
in Western civilization right now,
which is between the collectivists and
the individualist,
if you were to put it broadly,
but I want to talk about some of the
divisions among the individualist in
just a second.
First,
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at Birch gold.
So with the uncertainty of the of the
market right now with all of the
volatility,
a lot of Americans are increasingly
concerned about the security of their
savings.
And the Federal Reserve obviously has a
loose monetary policy.
It's been shoring up recently,
but there's a lot of volatility in the
markets.
Well,
this is the reason why I need to talk to
my friends over at Birch gold,
so vertical Dicom is the place to go.
If you want to put some of your assets
in precious metals.
Now I'm not saying take all of your
money out of the stock market and push
it and precious metals,
that'd be stupid,
but you should have a little bit in
precious metals to hedge against
inflation and volatility in the markets.
Vertical sells physical precious metals
for your own possession.
They'll ship metal right to your front
door and right now,
thanks to an irs tax law,
you can even move your Ira.
Are Eligible for a one k into an IRA
backed by physical gold or silver if you
so choose.
It's a good option for people who want
to ensure that their retirement savings
are protected from the possibility of
inflation or stock market volatility.
Gold group,
they have a really good long standing
track record of continued success.
They've been advertising with me for
years,
thousands of satisfied clients,
countless five star reviews and a plus
rating with the better business bureau.
Ask All your questions about precious
metals investing,
get all your answers,
and then contact Birch Gold's group to
request a free information kit on
physical precious metals.
They're comprehensive 16 page get shows
how gold and silver can protect your
savings,
how you can legally move that IRA or 400
k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA.
If that's something you're interested
in.
They get a no cost,
no obligation kit.
Head over to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible].
That's [inaudible] dot com slash Ben.
That also wants to know that we sent
you.
Okay,
so Jordan,
one of the things that we've been
talking about obviously is the big gap
that I think we certainly agree on
between the collectivists identity
politics and,
and the sublimation of science in favor
of subjective politics that favors a
power group.
Uh,
but I,
I want to talk a little bit about a
division that is also now breaking out
among those of us who I think would
consider yourselves friends of the
enlightenment.
So you consider yourself a friend of the
enlightenment style thinking at least in
the essence that individuality matters.
And if the individual is sovereign
scientific nf at the end that it
matters,
right?
Data matters are useful.
Exactly.
And,
and in this group,
you know,
I consider myself as part of this group,
people have started to call it the
intellectual dark web.
Sam Harris is part of this group.
Uh,
there,
there are a wide variety of folks with a
lot of broad political differences that
are part of this group.
But there are some real differences that
are broken out even among people who
consider themselves part of this group.
Right?
Steven pinker has a different
perspective on the world then,
then you do a,
I have a different perspective than Sam
Harris does.
You and I have our differences probably
on some matters of philosophy.
So where do you think that the
vulnerability lies in the,
in the possibility of vivifying
enlightenment mentality?
Because it seems to me that one of the
big problems that's,
that's popping its head up above the
water now is the rejection of the
enlightenment in favor of this old style
tribalism that you've been talking
about.
That we're now going to repeat history
because we benefited so much from the
enlightenment and we forget that things
don't have to be this way,
but we've got so much nice stuff.
We live in so much freedom that we
forget that if we just tossed those
enlightenment ideals out the window,
things get really ugly again.
I think that's what unites us
well,
that,
that's the question is what,
what,
what do you toss out the window before
things get ugly,
right?
And the enlightenment proponents,
you could say Harris,
you could say pinker,
um,
Charles Taylor in Canada,
they trace back the development of the
modern self.
Let's say Taylor wrote a book called
sources of the modern self to the
enlightenment.
And it's quite interesting because like
if you look at the typical academic
psychologists say their historical
knowledge generally runs back about 15
years.
And so because they're all concerned
with the,
with the modern literature and there's
some utility in that.
But the downside is they don't have any
historical context.
So you read someone like Taylor and you
think,
wow,
he's stretching it back 500 years,
you know,
but there's,
there's reading that goes way beyond
that to look at the sources of the self
and the source of the modern ethos,
and this is a huge bone of contention
between people like me saying people
like Harris and I think between people
like you and people like us is that my
sense is that the enlightenment values
themselves are grounded in an ethos
that's much deeper and much less
articulated.
And that would be an ethos of metaphor,
image,
drama,
ritual,
religion,
art,
music,
all of that dance even for that matter,
the nonverbal,
the pattern recognition.
Ian Mcgilchrist has written a book
called Master and his emissary,
which lays that out quite nicely with
regards to hemispheric specialization.
It's kind of predicated on Elk Conan
Goldberg's observation that the left
hemisphere is specialized for what we
know and the right hemisphere is
specialized for what we don't know if
that's an order chaos dynamic.
And the rough idea would be that the
left hemisphere generates paradigmatic
systems.
So that would be like the enlightenment
system,
axiom predicated,
right?
Even stainable axiom predicated,
but that that entire axiomatic system is
based in a nonverbal,
in the nonverbal domain that's
associated with while it would be
associated with the right hemisphere,
but it would also be associated with
deep motivations,
biological motivations and emotions.
And so because here,
here's one way of looking at it.
You think,
well,
how do you validate an axiomatic system
of ethics?
And the answer is quite straightforward.
John Psj figured this out is you play it
out in the world,
literally you acted out in the world and
then you watch each other's emotional
responses and if the thing that you're
playing out,
if the axiomatic system that you're
playing out satisfies the motivations
and the emotions of the people who are
engaged in that system,
then the system is justified and then
you say,
well,
it's not just that their motivations and
emotions are satisfied.
It's more complex.
It's that the motivations and emotions
of each individual are satisfied,
but not only now but now next week,
next month and next year.
So you have to extend it across time.
And not only my emotions and
motivations,
but yours as well.
Now,
next week,
next month,
and across time.
So this,
there's terribly tight constraints that
are placed upon an act.
An axiomatic system is validity.
Now the way jump,
piaget thought of that,
he said,
well,
think about it like a child's game.
A bunch of kids get together and they
decided to play pretend okay and pretend
is let's mortal the world,
right?
And,
and as a place to act,
because to pretend you don't,
right?
So the kids get together and they assign
roles and they say,
well,
you're going to be mom,
you're going to be dead,
you're going to be the dog and we're
going to play house.
And then they,
they acted out and what they're doing is
seeing if they can regulate the manner
in which they're constructing the game
so that everyone's emotions and
motivations are so well satisfied that
they want to continue the game.
Okay?
And so that's so cool.
So what it shows you is,
that's how an ethical system is,
is tested and justified.
It's like you play it out and you see if
everyone wants to keep playing,
and so that's a whole different
methodology than the scientific domain,
right?
So the axiomatic system isn't.
The ethical axiomatic system isn't
justified by reference to the scientific
method.
It's justified by reference to the
emotional and motivational wellbeing of
all the players of the game.
Now that game me emerges,
this is the second part of this and this
is so cool.
Then the question is,
well,
how does that game emerge?
And the answer is the same way that
children's games emerges.
So what Piaget noted is that kids would
get together and they play marbles and
if they were young kids,
they could all play marbles say six,
six years old,
they can all play marbles.
And,
and if they were in a group,
they were playing marbles and it all
worked out fine squabbles and all the
kids would keep playing,
right?
Validating the game.
But if you took the kids out of the game
and you said,
what are the rules of the game,
they would give completely disparate
accounts.
So they knew how to do.
It was like the,
the wisdom was in the group,
the wisdom was fragmented enough among
the individuals,
so if you pull the individuals out,
they'd give disparate accounts,
but if you put them altogether,
they could play the game,
but then if you waited until they were
11 or 12 and you pulled them out of the
game,
then they can tell you the rules.
Then at 14 or 15 they would be willing
to.
This is with more sophisticated games,
they would be more willing to regard
themselves as makers of the rules.
Okay,
so here's how it happens in an
evolutionary sense.
People going all the way back to our
primate forebears organize themselves
into functional hierarchies.
Okay?
And the hierarchies are complex and
they're not just based on power.
Despite what the idiot marks is,
say,
even if the wall has noted that
chimpanzee hierarchies are unstable,
if they're only based on power,
they don't last.
They generate into violence.
So you have a hierarchy that's,
that works,
but it's acted out.
No one knows why it works.
It works because everyone seems to be
happy with it.
Okay?
And so those hierarchies get more
complex and more sophisticated and then
people start to observe them and talk
about them.
It's like,
oh,
we've got this hierarchy here,
what's it like?
And then they spin off dramas about the
hierarchy.
Here's a hero who climbed up the
hierarchy and here's what a hero looks
like.
Okay,
so then you get the idea of hierarchy
and then you get the idea of the hero as
the person who moves up the hierarchy
and generates it.
Okay.
Then out of that you get the extraction
of the idea of the hero and then you get
development of that idea and it's out of
that.
You get the monotheistic religions and
so it's like the procedure and the
hierarchy come first.
No one knows what the rules are.
It's all played out the same way that
we'll just play it out in the pack or
chimpanzees play it out in their troop.
Then we wake up and think,
oh,
we live in a structure.
Here's the structure.
That would be,
oh,
Cyrus,
in the Egyptian mythologies.
Here's the structure,
here's how the structure goes wrong.
Here's what the structure does.
Here's its tyranny,
tyrannical aspect,
here's what you have to do to generate
the structure and to thrive it.
Okay?
That's even more important.
The hierarchy is important enough,
but what we want to know is how to
master the hierarchy.
Okay?
That's where you get the mythologies of
the hero.
Okay,
and then so then there's generates all
sorts of different heroes because
there's different ways of being
successful.
Then you have a panoply of heroes.
Then you think,
okay,
well now we've got all those heroes.
That's a set we can move,
pull back and say,
okay,
something about all these heroes is what
makes them heroes.
That's when you extract out the
monotheistic savior,
because that's why in Christianity,
Christ is the king of kings.
It's actually,
you can think about it as a literal
statement for forget about the religious
overlay.
It's like,
okay,
you got a bunch of people.
Some of them are kind of king,
like,
okay,
so you admire them.
It's like for whatever reason that is
right.
It's not easy to figure out why you
admire someone,
right?
That's complicated,
but let's say you've got to admire
admirable people.
You start telling stories about that's
why you go to a movie,
right?
You want to go watch someone.
You don't care about your board by.
No,
you want to go watch someone admirable
and interesting or maybe the opposite of
that.
It doesn't matter.
It's the same thing.
Then you think,
okay,
well we've got all these admirable
people.
They're generating the world properly.
That's what makes them admirable.
There is a principle they embody and
that principle is the process by which
the admirable world is generated.
That's the logos.
Okay?
That's the thing that's operative at the
beginning of,
and here's my.
Here's my question about about all of
this because now we're really not
talking about 12 rules for life as much
as naps.
Meaning which is your first book which
you're doing need the audio recording
audio.
It's,
it's,
it's definitely a harder book,
a then 12 rules for life and a much more
complex book and a lot of ways than the
12 rules for life.
So how universal are these systems?
Meaning,
why isn't that the enlightenment only
arrives at one time in human history,
in one place,
in human history as opposed to if human
biology is essentially consistent
across,
you know,
across humanity.
Then why is it that that you know,
if at the,
at the apex of the levels you adapt with
the enlightenment idea which started
this particular question,
then why is it that it only arrives in
one place at one time as opposed to
arriving in a variety of places in a
variety of different kinds of great
culture and that's okay.
The first thing we would say is the
process by which this,
the hierarchy itself and success within
the hierarchy is generated.
That's to be accounted over millions of
years,
at least hundreds,
thousands of thousands of years,
but I would push it back because you can
see analogs in the chimps,
so 20 million years,
let's say.
That's a long time on that timescale.
The fact that the enlightenment values
of in Europe 500 years ago before
anywhere else,
it's like,
well,
who cares?
It's.
It's five old men long,
right?
If you put five 100 mineral men in line,
it's like it's yesterday,
it's this morning,
so we've.
We've evolved these hierarchical
structures.
That's our culture.
We've evolved ways of maneuvering within
the hierarchical structures that are
successful and now we've started to
evolve ways of mapping our,
our adaptation,
not just adapting but mapping it.
Okay,
so how does the mapping occur?
First,
admiration,
second,
invitation of admiration,
and that would be drama.
It's like you,
you dramatize Shakespeare,
extracts out what's admirable and
interesting and plays it out,
so that's the use of the body as a
representational structure of the body.
So we act out what's admirable.
You think,
okay,
now we've kind of got the drama down,
were all captured by this drama.
It's like,
well then the literary critics come
along,
the philosophers and they say,
oh,
what are the principles by which the
admirable people operate?
It's like chimps woke up and said,
oh,
well some chimps are more successful
than others.
What are the rules of success?
It's like,
well,
there were no rules because they weren't
running by rules.
There aren't rules until you described
the patterns.
Then you have a rule.
That's what happens with Moses by the
women,
right?
Moses has a revelation.
Here's the rules.
It's like,
yeah,
we'd been living out those rules
forever,
but we didn't know what they were
because they weren't rules.
They were customs.
Right?
Okay,
so you start by mapping your customs in
drama and story and that way you can
represent them and you can transmit
them.
Then once you have them in your grip,
say the representative now not just act
it out,
well then you can move one step backward
from them and you can say,
well,
what's the commonalities among these?
What are the general principles?
That would be the development of
something like the code of Hammurabi,
right?
It's like,
well,
we've got all these customs.
What are they?
Right.
Revelation.
It's like,
Oh,
here's how you map the customs.
That's the decalogue.
It's the same idea.
So I took human beings are very long
time to evolve their hierarchies,
to evolve their structures of success,
and then to have enough people around
with enough spare time to engage in the
cultural process of the artistic
cultural process of mapping the adaptive
structure,
not only merges in mythology and drama,
then that lays the groundwork for
philosophy.
Then the philosophers could come in,
especially once it's written,
like in the Judeo Christian Pantheon.
It's like,
oh,
now we've got it written down.
Oh well we don't have to remember it.
We can read it and while we're reading
we can think about it.
And so then out of that starts to come
the semantic codes.
Well then you get the enlightenment.
It's like,
okay,
well here's a bunch of semantic codes.
It's like,
yeah,
those are great.
So this is really interesting because
you know,
if you read pinker or if regional
Goldberg's new book,
essentially they attribute the
enlightenment to Jonah.
Colbert calls it the miracle it.
It's almost as though it accidentally
occurred in a certain place at a certain
time.
Joan doesn't quite go quite that far.
I think to be fair to him,
but uh,
I think that that philosophy that this
sort of sprang up randomly here,
uh,
is,
is very much embedded in a lot of Sam
Harris is thinking a lot of thinking and
you're taking it further back.
But I do wonder if this may be an area
of actual disagreements.
We have two of us.
It should be fun.
Are you attributing the growth of the
Judaeo Christian ethic that emerges into
the enlightenment as also accidentally
just pushing timeline further back?
You think it's accidental?
Okay.
I'm not making a reduction to start.
So the first thing is I'm going to say
this is how religion evolved,
but I'm not saying,
I'm not saying that this explanation
exhausts the phenomena because it's a
very strange phenomenon.
It's very,
very strange,
but,
but that doesn't mean we can't generate
a plausible evolutionary account.
So like if you have a bunch of motivated
emotional limited beings occupying the
same territory and competing and
cooperating for the same resources,
including the resource of cooperation
which can generate more resources,
is not a zero sum game.
There are going to be patterns of
adaptation that emerged from that,
that are similar.
So here's a way of thinking about it.
If you put a bunch of kids together,
they're gonna evolve games,
right?
Well which games?
Well,
a bunch of different games.
Yeah,
but they're all games,
right?
So even though.
So that's the moral relativist element.
A bunch of different games.
But the moral absolute establishment is,
yeah.
Yeah,
but they're all games and the games have
to be playable,
which means they have to continue in an
iterative way.
Right?
So that's a big constraint.
People have to want to play them.
So not only did they have to be games,
no,
and comprehensible to everybody hand
enjoyable,
but people,
but they have to be self maintaining and
everyone has to want to play with them.
Okay.
That's the answer to the postmodern
conundrum.
A plethora of potential ethical
implications of the world and infinite
variety.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fine.
Not an infinite variety of pragmatically
applicable interpretations.
You instantly constrained the universe
to while too,
to what?
Well,
this is why there's commonalities in
mythologies.
It's like if you put enough people
together in enough different places,
the commonality of the groups of people
there because of the grounding in common
motivation and emotion and embodiment,
because we're embodied,
means that they're gonna generate
hierarchies that are broadly similar
with strategies of success within those
with descriptions of the strategies that
are broadly similar,
and so you could say in some sense,
the ethic that gave rise to the
enlightenment is in place more or less
everywhere.
Now.
It's tricky because not every
hierarchical system is as functional as
every other hierarchical system.
Some of them can degenerate into
tyranny.
We're talking about the set of all
voluntarily playable games or something
like that,
and that can degenerate out of that.
You're going to get common myths.
You have to and then that and that lays
the groundwork that lays the groundwork
for even our ability to communicate.
Right?
Right.
So,
and this is,
the enlightenment dies.
They just,
they're not getting that.
So,
and this gets to,
I think,
the broader question that I know you and
Sam went on for three hours about,
about the nature of truth.
He has a particularly truth in the moral
sphere.
I think that.
Yeah.
Um,
and what would it be fair to say that
you guys agree on the idea of truth in
the scientific sphere that did you know
if,
if something is that there is such a
thing as objective truth or are you
going to say we agree on a lot of that.
The question is to some degree,
why do scientists accept the idea that
objective truth is true?
And then I would say we probably don't
agree about that because I would ground
that in and Sam would ground out in the
idea of an independently existing
objective world,
right?
Which is a leap of faith,
more like my own actually than the
pragmatist view.
Right?
And if you believe that there's a god
who's out there in the universe who
created the structures and in particular
certain way than what he created is the
truth.
And it is apart from you.
And if human beings didn't exist and
they weren't able to utilize the truth,
that truth would still exist out there,
whereas the pragmatists might say it's
truth is in the use that it has for him.
That's the thing is that,
you know,
I don't know if we would consider a
scientific truth true unless we are also
simultaneously accepting the idea that
scientific truth is good for people.
So there's one other thing I wanted to
bring up that's relevant because you
brought up the idea of God.
So here's a way of thinking about it.
And,
and I don't know what to make of this
because this is stretching me.
This is stretching my thoughts out
beyond where I've been able to develop
them.
So this is the intuition that I have
based on a variety of things,
experiences I've had.
So imagine that there's a very wide
range of human behaviors,
okay?
And some subset of those are both
admirable and not admirable.
So let's call them good and evil at
this,
at the extreme.
So okay.
Then we might say,
well,
there's a pattern that characterizes all
the actions that are good and a pattern
that characterizes all the actions that
are evil,
and that's a transpersonal pattern
because it's,
it's not just about me,
it's about everyone.
Okay?
And so then that gets persona fund.
That's Christ and Satan,
let's say,
or Cain and Abel,
right?
That gets personified.
And that's a bad guy,
a good guy in a movie,
like it's personified all the time.
It's thor and Loki.
And then the marvel movies,
you know,
so now you have the,
let's say you take the idea of Christ
and you think,
okay,
so that's the abstraction of everything
that's,
that's admirably good about the set of
all human behaviors.
Okay?
And then you think,
well,
what sort of reality does that have?
And this pulls back into the reality of
the idea of the logo.
Send the idea that it was the logos that
God used at the beginning of time to
extract order out of chaos.
So you think,
well,
it's transpersonal,
the goodness,
because it's not just characterized
stick of any one person.
It's more like something that inhabits a
person other than that a person is.
You can really see this,
for example,
on the other end too,
with the satanic end,
because if you read the writings of
people who do absolutely horrific things
like the shooters,
you can see that possession
extraordinarily clearly.
If your eyes are open,
it's like an.
It's shocking,
so people don't usually look at it and
they even say that themselves,
like the columbine kids,
their writings or hair raising,
you know,
and they were called clearly possessed
by an evil that you only encounter if
you sit in a dark place and brood on
your hatred for months and years,
right?
You go places that you go places where
all the dark people go,
right?
Right.
And then that it,
that takes you over.
Okay.
So the good and can take you over as
well.
Okay.
So there's this,
there's this spirit of good,
let's say,
and what the spirit of good does is act
in the world on the potential of the
world to generate the actuality of the
world.
And the Judeo Christian proposition is,
is that if you confront the potential of
the world with good in mind,
using truth,
truthful communication,
then the order that you extract is good.
And then that's echoed in genesis when
God is using the word and he creates
cosmos audit potential.
And every time he does that he says,
and it was good.
Which is,
I think it's so interesting because
there's a proposition there and the
proposition there is that if you
encounter potential with truth,
the cosmos you create is actually good.
Well,
that's,
that's just an absolutely overwhelming
idea.
It's like if it's true,
if it's true,
it's the greatest idea that river
watson.
Yeah,
like your,
your,
your thoughts on this.
Actually from maps of meeting help
generate what we in a injuries and
called Barataria and Hebrew leading into
a thought about the,
about the,
uh,
the Bible.
But this merged with a little diversity
alien thought led me to the idea that
when it comes to the mystical notion of
the tree of good and evil in,
in Eden,
what does that supposed to be?
What did,
what did people do wrong by eating from
the tree of good and evil,
and my feeling is that what they did
wrong is that God created a universe in
which the value was embedded in the
object right there in the same way that
you in your,
in your book,
talk about if you're teaching a child
about an object,
the rules of the object are embedded in
the teaching about the object.
So you use the example of the vase.
We were discussing this earlier,
um,
but you used the example of a vase where
you teach your child,
don't touch the base because the base
will break so that the rules embedded in
the object in the same way in
Aristotelian thought,
the rules for behavior are embedded in
the nature of the universe.
Meaning what makes a man good is what
makes them unique,
which is the reason they ideas.
The reason is what makes me unique.
So acting in accordance with right
reason is what makes something is what
makes an action good.
So if you believe that God created the
universe along these lines and what
natural law is just a human attempt to
understand the lines along which created
God created the universe,
then we're human beings went wrong is
when they decided to separate values
from the universe.
When we decided to take values and say,
this is a completely separate thing,
so this base has no rules attached to it
anymore.
It's just a vase and we can construct
the rules,
arbitrarily is to what to do with this
vase,
and so eating from the tree of knowledge
of good and evil changes the nature of
good and evil from the universe comes
along with a set of rules to human
beings.
Think that they can use their own
intuition to supplant God's rules and
discipline universal rules with their
own particular vision of what the
universe ought to be and at that point
they have to be expelled for.
Okay,
okay.
So that's also associated to some
degree,
I would say with Milton's warning and
paradise lost because Milton basically
portrays Lucifer,
who's the bringer of light.
Weirdly enough,
as the spirit of unbridled rationality,
which accounts for the say the Catholic
Church antagonism,
the Catholic churches,
antagonism towards rationality,
the idea was same idea and the Tower of
Babel that human beings have a
proclivity to direct their own dogmatic,
um,
ethical systems and then to expand them
into a grandiosity that challenges the
transcendent and that that's a
totalitarian catastrophe.
And for Milton,
Satan was the spirit that eternally does
that,
right?
Who says everything I know is enough.
That's the plants.
What I don't know,
that supplants that transcendent and
that that's a catastrophe.
How that's tangled up with the,
with the knowledge of good and evil,
while you're making some headway
towards,
towards sorting that out.
I mean there is a cataclysm that's,
it's explained in,
in,
in the story of Adam and Eve,
right?
The cataclysm is the coming two to
wakefulness and its associated partly
with recognition of nakedness,
which is recognition of vulnerability
and Mortel and ham,
the discovery of death.
And then also the discovery of good and
evil that goes along with that.
So you said,
well,
that's partly that.
The cognitive division of ethics from
the facts of the object,
so I have to think that through.
I would also recommend to people,
I think I mentioned this before,
is Ian mcgilchrist spoken,
the master and his emissary because he
looks at this neuropsychologically right
and and looks at the left hemisphere as
the hemisphere that's dealing with the
explicitly axiomotic systems and the
right hemisphere that's dealing with
what those systems are embodied in.
Okay,
so part of what happens with the
emergence of good and evil,
it's as far as I could tell,
it took me a long time to think about
this is the w,
and this is different than the than the
hypothesis that you laid forward,
which is why I can't reconcile that
exactly as you recognize,
you're naked.
You know you can be hurt.
You know you're vulnerable and
insufficient.
You hide from God because that's what
happens next,
and the reason you hide from God say God
is your destiny or God is the.
You're walking with God is a
manifestation of your ultimate,
proper destiny.
You,
you doubt whether you're capable of that
because now you realize you're embodied
finitude your nakedness and
insufficiency,
so you hide in your ashamed.
So there's that.
You also realize that you can be hurt
and suffer and that Kinda goes along
with God's command,
that you're going to work in the sweat
of your brow and that you're going to
die and that women are going to be
subjugated to men,
which has put on as a curse,
not as a moral imperative,
right?
Um,
but then what emerges out of that is
that as soon as you,
you know that you can be hurt,
and this is what differentiates us from
other animals,
and you really think that through,
here's all the myriad ways I can be
hurt.
Then you're angry about that because you
can be heard,
but even worse,
you can figure out how to hurt other
people.
And,
and so that's part of that knowledge of
good and evil.
You associated with this dissociation of
the,
of the object from its ethical can
obtain the right of the universe has
created by God from our interpretation
of the universe that there is a gap
between the two and that once human
beings begin to supplant their own
rationality for a telus right in,
in the diversity here and that geology
well we end up doing is creating all
sorts of awful systems that end up
destroying us in the show.
But something about that.
That's right.
I mean,
part of what happens in the new
testament as far as I can tell is that
what Christ says,
so he's trying to transcend the rule
structure might be not because there's
anything wrong with the rule.
If they're necessary precondition for
discipline,
which is actually white wrote 12 rooms,
right?
It's like you need rules but there,
but rules conflict and they don't always
apply and so there has to be an ethic
underlying the rules and you should have
more respect for the ethic than for the
rule.
Right?
Okay.
Christ's idea,
and this is part of the idea of the
reestablishment of paradise,
is that you should orient yourself
towards the good and that's something
like an alliance with God and then that
you should tell the truth and that's the
ethic that generated the rules to begin
with.
Okay,
and then we can be serious about this,
you know,
and we can say,
well,
how do you adjudicate the reality of
that claim?
Right?
So then we might think,
well,
we already walked through the fact that
the heroes of the past acted on
potential to extract out the world of
actuality and if they did that properly,
then the world they extracted was good
and that that is a divine principle.
And then we might say,
well,
he hasn't been defined principles and
you might say,
well what is it that's acting through
people in the good,
like the Christian theological answer to
that would be the logos,
right?
That's the idea.
That's the idea of the Holy Spirit,
roughly speaking,
right?
Might think,
well,
is that a real thing?
It's like,
well,
to me it's real the same way that
consciousness is real and we don't know
the role of consciousness in determining
reality even,
but even if you're an evolutionary
biologist,
and this is so interesting because the
evolutionary biologists actually
discriminate,
differentiated themselves from Darwin on
this point,
like Darwin was very,
very forthright in his claim that sexual
selection was as powerful as natural
selection or even more so and so that,
so here's where this that goes in and
because that was because that brought
consciousness into the world as an
active player,
the materialistic evolutionary biologist
ignored that,
so like 150 years and only concentrated
on natural selection where they could
play.
While this is all chance,
it's like sexual selection is not
chance.
Okay,
so here's a hypothesis.
Human being separated themselves from
chimpanzees.
One of the reasons they did that was
because human females are sexually
selective.
Chimps aren't.
Chimps will female chimps in estrus will
mate with any chimp.
The main chimps that dominant ones
chased the subordinate males away so
they're more likely to have offspring,
but it's not because of female choice
right now.
Female human females have done this
whole different things that they've,
they've,
they,
they have hidden fertility and they're
much more likely to go after guys who
have climbed up the hierarchy.
So let's say heroes will give the
women's some credit for intelligence,
right?
And say that that's what they're after,
even if they are using wealth and so
forth and status as a marker,
they're actually using those as a marker
for competence.
And,
and I think that's,
I think the evidence think the evidence
for that is clear.
Okay.
So you might say,
oh well it was human female conscious
choice that selected us.
Okay.
And you think,
well that's not random,
that's not random at all.
It's the farthest thing from random that
there is.
And that means consciousness is making
it's choices with regards to what
propagates,
but then it's even more complex than
that.
So here's what happens among men.
The man all get together in their
hierarchy,
they pause a valued goal.
They all accept that as the goal because
otherwise they wouldn't be cooperating,
right?
Then they arrange themselves into a
hierarchy and they let the most
competent guys lead because they want to
get to.
They want to get to the promised land.
They want to get the most competent
leaders leaning,
right?
Competent defined by that value.
Okay,
so here's what happens.
Essentially the men all get together and
vote on the good man and the good men
are then chosen by the women and those
are the people who propagate and so it's
like men are voting on which men get to
reproduce and women are going along with
the vote and and being even more
stringent in their,
in their choices,
let's say.
And so then what you get is that the
consciousness that through its active
expression transforms the potential of
the world into actuality also selects
the direction of evolution.
Right?
And that's where the meme darkens term
turns into the biological reality.
It's not interested in.
So yeah,
this is something that's so cool about
darkens.
It's like I've often thought this about
Dawkins is if he would push his thinking
to the limits,
he would fall right into young.
The men,
he'd be lost because that's a whole
other universe,
but if you take that mean seriously,
like and I mean really seriously think,
yeah,
there's some ways of conceptualizing
that becomes so all encompassing,
right?
They start to become an actual force of
evolution itself,
and so then here's the case.
You could make consciousness extracts
the proper world of being from potential
through truth and then it's good.
It's like,
okay,
that's a hard one,
man.
That manifests itself in human beings at
the individual level of individual
consciousness.
That's the logos with it.
That's the metaphysical foundation of
the idea of natural right and
responsibility.
Hey,
that's a bloody killer idea.
That's expressed in the hero of heroes.
That idea,
that hero of heroes is the driving force
behind human evolution,
so not only do you get the action of the
logos metaphysically as the process that
extracts order out of chaos at the
beginning of time.
You also get it as the major driver of
evolution,
and so then you ask,
okay,
then what kind of reality does that
have?
Because you chase consciousness back and
like it disappears into the mystery of
our past and we have no idea what it's
relationship is with matter,
but it's the forest that gives rise to
the cosmos and drives evolution.
It's like you're getting pretty close to
God.
They're even just pragmatically
speaking.
You're certainly not close to you,
but in the midst of it,
an argument about free will because
obviously if you.
If you make the hard determinist
argument,
that free will doesn't exist and the
consciousness is merely a sort of trick
that your brain is playing itself.
Then how exactly does.
How does culture propagate?
How do,
how do these means propagate?
How are people choosing sexual selection
and natural selection become one of the
same as soon as you boil sexual
selection down to natural selection.
And also I think that the freewill
argument,
I mean I see why Harris gets tangled up
in that,
you know,
because well first of all,
deterministic arguments are unbelievably
powerful and when we use deterministic
models for many things,
they really were right.
So you could say,
well,
we're going to use that by default.
It's like,
fair enough.
We're gonna deviate from that with care,
but I don't see people as driven like
clocks winding down.
First of all,
we don't wind down in any simple way.
We're dissipative structures to use.
Um,
he wrote Schrodinger what is life a
human being as a dissipative structure?
We're not,
we're not an entropic structure like a
clock running down.
We are in some sense,
but as living beings,
we pull energy in and so we're not
winding down like a deterministic
structure where something other than
that and the way we treat each other is
as logos,
as far as I can tell,
the way I treat myself,
if I'm going to be good to myself in the
proper sense,
is that I'm an active agent of choice
confronting and infinite landscape of
potential and casting that potential
into a reality for good or for evil.
Okay?
And if I treat myself that way,
then I have proper respect for myself
and proper fear of myself because I can
make bad decisions and work the
structure of reality.
And I think if you read Frankel through
example or Solzhenitsyn and you see how
your bad decisions can work,
the structure of reality,
then that wakes you up,
right?
Okay.
So there's that.
If you don't treat yourself like a,
an active agent imbued with logos,
then your life doesn't go away,
but more if you don't treat other people
that way,
they do not want to play with you.
If we set up societies that aren't
predicated on the idea that people are
like that,
then the society's become,
they'd dissolve or they become
totalitarian almost instantly.
So then I would say,
well,
you've got the problem of determinism
was like,
fair enough,
man.
How do you reconcile the fact that if
you lay out a society at every level of
the analysis on strict deterministic
grounds,
it fails.
So it doesn't,
doesn't have any in your hypothesis has
a flaw.
I mean,
maybe not.
Maybe you can say no,
the facts are independent of the ethical
concepts.
This is what are the truth.
This is where the truth pragmatism
question back into being right?
Because Sam say,
well,
it's true.
Regardless of what the effect is.
And you would say,
well,
it's obviously not true if morals are
constructed for pragmatic reason and if
this pragmatism
doesn't work,
if it falls into nothingness,
but also it also depends to some degree
on what you're willing to,
how you're willing to test your
hypothesis.
Because I might say,
well,
if your hypothesis is factually correct,
wouldn't you assume that if people base
their,
their behaviors individually and
familial and socially on that set of
facts,
which is basically what Sam claims about
facts to begin bandwidth.
If you base your ethos or not those
facts,
wouldn't it work?
Right?
Well,
he claims that that's a test and I'd
say,
well then it fails that test.
It doesn't work.
We have to treat each other like divine
centers of consciousness in order for
society to work.
Yes.
I think,
wow,
that's.
I can't see anything
way out of those arguments.
I,
I can't say they're obviously,
which is why you and I agree on so much
about this kind of stuff and I think
that it's also the reason why people
find your work really inspiring and
while the left wants to claim that you
are an angry person or they'll claim
similarly than I'm a deeply angry to.
I don't think there's been quite an
angry conversation.
I'm pretty sure it has not been,
um,
but I feel horrified by what the radical
left is capable of,
but that doesn't make me angry.
Exactly.
And,
and I think that it's,
it's demonstrative of why so many people
find what you're doing inspiring because
unlike the radical left which is
consumed with the idea of victim hood
and victimology and were victims of the
system like Marxism makes the claim that
the only way that peoplesoft is the
Clinton mark is a makes,
but the only way to cure people of
sucking is by changing the entire
system,
which will in some magical fashion
transform the nature of humanity in the
proper direction.
Right color.
Exactly the claim that you're making.
And I hope that I'm making as well,
is that human beings do soc unless they
decide to stop sucking,
right?
And,
and,
and your whole goal is to tell people
exactly how it is the bacon and clean up
their rooms.
You're a famous phrase.
Guts.
Yeah.
Well they might as well start.
Start
with what's right in front of them.
It's a lot harder than it looks because
to clean up your room means to accept
that it's actually necessary for you to
take that little bit of chaos that's in
front of you,
that chaotic potential and cast it into
habitable order.
And then you have to develop the right
attitude towards that.
It's like,
okay,
well I'm going to put my room in order.
Well what do you mean order is in
relationship to something you know,
like if your desk is ordered,
it means you've ordered it because
you're going to work there and you're
working there on something valuable.
And so the order is conceived of in
relationship to a tee loss.
It's like,
okay,
you're going to order your room.
Well what are you going to do in it?
Like what's your room for,
what's the purpose,
what's the purpose?
You can't order your room without
falling into purpose.
And I would say,
well,
if you're going to fall into purpose,
it's like try it out on a local scale
first,
right?
You don't want to go out there and
change the system.
It's like,
what the hell do you know?
Leave the system alone,
see what you can do locally,
see if you can put yourself together,
see if you can put your immediate
environment together and you'll find if
you're in a chaotic household and a
chaotic household would be one where no
one has any discipline.
No one has any ames and there's a
terrible battle between Cain and Abel
going on all the time.
Right?
So,
so life socks and everything is
miserable and more cynical and that's
what wisdom is.
It's like,
and there's no point in trying anything
because everything's meaningless than
who the hell is going to care in a
million years and you're a full to move
forward.
In any case,
it's like there's your household.
Okay?
And so now you decide.
No,
despite all that,
I'm going to put my room in order.
It was like you will have a war on your
hands because the first thing that
people around you who are aiming down,
we'll do is think,
oh,
you,
you really,
you think you're so much better than we
are?
Do you really think that you and your
fancy God damn plans?
It's like we're going to put every
psychological obstacle we can possibly
think of in your way because if you
succeed even in something that trivial,
you shed a very dim light on our
existence and so we're going to put,
we're going to do everything we can to
take you out,
and so this people think,
oh,
well,
it's cleaning your room.
That's just a cliche.
It's like,
yeah,
really?
I just go ahead and try it.
You see how much of a cliche that is and
if you've got your room in order,
then put your office in order.
See,
and then you're going to encounter.
The soon as you do that,
you step out into the social world.
You're going to encounter that antipathy
between men and women.
You're going to encounter the identity
politics in the workplace.
You're going to encounter how you
regulate your sexual morality while
you're working with people of the
opposite sex.
You're going to encounter the ethics
that are necessary to move your business
forward.
It's like the whole.
It's a microcosm.
It really is.
And so to take those microcosmic caused
him seriously.
Well,
that's what I'm asking people to do and
I'm saying,
look,
it isn't only about you being happy.
It's like,
yeah,
whatever,
pap.
There's lots of times in your life
you're not going to be happy,
and so that's not gonna work.
You want to have something meaningful
that's the boat that will take you
through the storm,
right when you batten down the hatches,
but there's more ads isn't even that.
It isn't even me.
A meaningful,
engaged life.
We'll see you through the catastrophes
even though that's a big deal,
right?
That's a great proposition.
And I really believe it's true because
you can say to yourself,
yeah,
it's worth it.
Right,
right and great.
And,
but there's the other part of it too,
which is don't be thinking that your
errors aren't linked to hell because
they are.
If you look at what happened in the 20th
century,
the brilliant commentators on the,
on the 20th century,
totalitarian states and all of their
atrocities said the same thing over and
over.
It isn't top down evil leader
manipulating innocent masses.
That's not it.
It's the moral failings of every single
individual unwilling to say their truth,
unwilling to act out what they know to
be right that accumulate and produce the
catastrophic state.
And so when you're fussing about with
your life,
when you're not manifesting your
potential,
when you're falsifying your speech and
your auctions in the service of short
term expedience,
you are working to bring about hell on
earth.
And that's true.
It's true.
Literally.
And then it's true.
It's.
I suspect it's also true metaphorically.
And that's a real truth man.
When you get the literal and
metaphorical working at the same time,
it's like that's,
that's real.
So it isn't just that you have to fix up
yourself so that you know you can have a
better life.
It's like,
who cares about you for a moment?
You know,
it's,
you have to fix up your life because if
you don't,
every time you make a mistake that you
know to be a mistake,
you are leading the world toward hell.
And I believe that.
I think it's true.
Well,
Jordan Peterson's book is 12 rules for
life.
Uh,
honestly,
I,
we could do this all day long and will
certainly have you back.
I really appreciate the time.
There's a reason so many people follow
Jordan.
There is some reason so many people are
buying this book.
The book is fantastic and his other book
maps meeting is also fantastic,
so they'll get a copy of that as well.
Jordan,
thanks so much for stopping by.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks Ben.
It was great.
Yep.
The venture pro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan.
Hey,
executive producer Jeremy Boren,
associate producers,
Mathis Glover and Austin Stevens edited
by Alex [inaudible].
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina.
Hair and makeup is by just while Alvera
the Ben Shapiro show.
Sunday special is a daily wire forward
publishing production copyright,
Ford publishing 2018.